la meilleure galette des rois se prépare
à noisy le roi c'est ici précisément que
l'on garde le secret de fabrication et
dont profite ses clients une bonne
galette vaut bien quelques minutes
d'attentes salut l'habitude cette
boulangerie bros wii pour moi mais c'est
tous les jours ne m'ont pas sauf le
lundi quand il est fermé
chez lui tout tous ces gâteaux à je suis
content je content pour lui
et puis pour nous parce qu'il ya plus de
monde encore lancé il ya quatre ans par
le syndicat des artisans boulangers
pâtissiers des yvelines près d'une
soixantaine de professionnels ont pris
part cette année au concours pour se
démarquer de la concurrence tout est
dans la recette de la farine du beurre
et de la poudre d'amandes savoir faire
un tour de main
on a mis les matières premières qui qui
ont été sélectionnés par un parent
aimant employés moi même on a travaillé
ensemble dessus donc c'était vraiment un
très beau produit trois jours offert le
faîtage laisser reposer donné les tours
et après laffaire la veille aucun repose
encore et la cure de bonnes jambes même
l'épiphanie passé les caprices du roy
proposeront des galettes jusqu'en
février comptait 32 euros pour un
produit entier est 600 pièces ont été
vendues en l'espace d'un week end